you mentioned cold showers wim hof have
you followed him at all do you find any
of his practices i did my breathing this
morning um however i gotta i'd love to
ask him about this and i i saw it in an
faq but i was doing the wim hof method
very successfully really enjoying it and
then one morning while doing it late
just like that i got hit with tinnitus
and i've had it ever since then i
checked then i i checked his faqs and
people been asking about tinnitus after
the wim hof method and it says don't
worry about it it goes away guess what
it hasn't gone away okay now 60 years of
age i just for the first time in my life
have tinnitus so if anybody's into wim
hof yes it's brilliant yes the cold
showers are brilliant and his meditation
teaching is probably great though i
haven't gone down that road
but the the breathing it in me
do i know it caused it well let me say
that it
it happened
bam right in the middle of doing the
breathing
so as far as i'm concerned
i stirred something there and yeah yeah
i don't want to dis the wim hof method
believe me if you haven't heard if
people listening haven't heard me it's
brilliant and i i like the cold shower
thing it really does zip me up i
but that happened to me anyway i'm i'm
venting a little on that because it's
unfortunate because i really enjoy the
breathing
whenever i do the wim hof exercise if
i'm doing it properly around that second
or third time that i hold my breath
then i get some tinnitus but it goes
away after about a minute my mine didn't
go away did you ever have temporary
tinnitus or you just had only permanent
tinnitus it just kicked in and never
left kicked in once and never left oh
boy
and i've never had it in my life
so you know i might i finally funny you
asked because i actually did the method
very brief i just did a short version of
the method this morning first time in
about three months because my ears have
calmed down you know and
that's back
at stan aleister asks have you ever used
any of wim hof's cold endurance
techniques if so can these extend one
survival in harsh conditions
uh
if if the harsh condition is being
submersed in ice cold water sure
because that's what it is uh yeah
that'll extend that you jump out of a
boat in alaska i mean that's probably
going to help that absolutely i think
but then overall sure i mean i do
believe and agree with the with the
concept of it um simply because i felt
my own body felt stronger and felt
better because of doing the wim hof
methods so yeah i i like i said
notwithstanding our earlier conversation
about potential tinnitus from the
breathing um yeah i think wim's on to
something pretty great uh and and i do
adhere i haven't gotten into his
meditative techniques yet but the first
i've got steps one and step two
definitely